Vielleicht hat er anfang märz mitbekommen der russische präsident wladimir putin hat in seiner rede an die nation eine ganze serie neuer nuklearwaffen
vorgestellt angefangen bei raketen die mit 10 facher schallgeschwindigkeit fliegen
unbemannte atom u boote und atomwaffen die jedes gegnerische abwehr system überwinden
angeblich doch wie genau sollen putins wunderwaffen funktionieren und was ist wirklich dran an diesen russischen
rüstungsprojekten ein hoch brisantes thema das ihr euch auf whatsapp gewünscht, habt danke dafür und herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Wie ihr täglich an die neuesten infos aufkommt und bei klick zum mitmachen können dass er vater am ende
des videos die rede vom russischen präsidenten
fand zwei wochen vor der russischen präsidentenwahl statt und zeitweise klang ist tatsächlich eher wie ein science fiction
beispielsweise als wladimir putin die schwere
interkontinentalrakete
Hat einen neuartigen
torpedo sowie ein marschflugkörper
der atom betrieben ist
vorstellte an dieser stelle sehen die zuschauer das video einer rakete die rasend schnell aufsteigt dann folgt eine
computeranimation die zeigt wie der marschflugkörper
Europa, um runde den atlantik in richtung süden hinter sich lässt und dann über dem pazifik richtung norden fliegt die botschaft dahinter ist mehr als
klar
russland präsentiert einen waffentyp der
Problemlos jeden ort auf der erde erreicht und auch in der lage ist die westküste der usa zu treffen angetrieben mit
nuklearenergie doch die rakete wird russischen angaben zufolge nicht nur mit atomenergie betrieben sondern trägt
Zudem eine atomwaffe an bord und das liebe leute das wäre tatsächlich eine große sensation vor allen dingen der antrieb denn atomkraft liefert
Im vergleich zu anderen antriebsarten sehr viel mehr energie pro masse und somit wäre das grundproblem
Des raketen ausgelöst denn bisher galt um eine große reichweite zu erzielen ist viel treibstoff
notwendig doch der wiederum reduziert die reichweite also ein fliehendes ziel
Ja aber das war es noch nicht mit putins neuem waffenprogramm außerdem, mit dabei die hyperschall rakete kinosaal übersetzt
So viel wie durch den ausbau des russischen
Arsenals bezeichnete putin als reaktion auf das verhalten der usa zitat es geht
um neue strategische
raketensysteme russlands die wir entwickelt haben als reaktion auf den einseitigen ausstieg der vereinigten staaten aus dem vertrag über
raketenabwehr und die de facto stationierung solcher systeme auf dem gebiet der vereinigten staaten und außerhalb der
Amerikanischen grenzen so putin die ausdehnung der nato grenzen. Habe russland gezwungen solch ein verteidigungssystem
aufzubauen all diese waffen sind aus russland funktionstüchtig eines der waffensysteme sei bereits jetzt bei den truppen und jederzeit bereit für einen kampfeinsatz
In einem interview mit einem amerikanischen sender bestätigte vladimir putin auch
zu einem späteren zeitpunkt noch einmal dass alle tests erfolgreich verlaufen seien zudem gäbe es keine
Abwehrsysteme weltweit die gegen diese wunderwaffen an canon mit den. Hyperschall waffen
habe russland beispielsweise enorme vorteile
Im bewaffneten kampf und ein direkter angriff auf sein land würde im übrigen auch mit aller konsequenz
Beantwortet werden fest steht jedenfalls mit seiner rhetorik hat putin die ganze
Welt aufhorchen lassen doch expertinnen und netzwerken sind sich tatsächlich uneinig darüber ob die präsentierten waffen wie beschrieben
funktionieren einige
forschungsgruppen bezweifeln gar die existenz
Dieser russischen waffensysteme andere coach ingo ist experte im bereich
militärtechnik und hat in einem unabhängigen russischen fernsehsender zu bedenken gegeben dass
Einiges in putins rede zu aggressiv dargestellt wurde vielmehr handelt es sich bei vielen waffen
um eine weiterentwicklung bereits bestehender dazu coach ingo die
Interkontinentalrakete salat ist eine modernisierung einer rakete die in den 1970 er und 80 er jahren gebaut wurde sie wird in denselben alten
Raketen schächten stationiert werden im vergleich zu amerikanischen
waffensystemen sei sie mit eingesetztem flüssigtreibstoff sogar eher rückständig
Das gezeigte video ist sogar zehn jahre alt und wurde schon mal zur bebilderung des vorgängermodells
eingesetzt bezüglich des atomgetriebenen
marschflugkörper schließt sich der russische militärexperte der meinung europäischer raketen expertinnen und experten an die
grundsätzliche zweifel anmelden ein marsch für körper mit einem kleinen
atomkraftwerk sag einfach viel zu schwer um zu funktionieren
zudem sei es bereits in den 50er und 60er jahren sowohl von den usa als auch von der sowjetunion getestet worden die
ergebnisse waren ernüchternd auch andere fachleute haben starke zweifel denn wie soll solch eine rakete ohne
jahrelange umfangreiche tests zur einsatzreife gebracht worden seien deutsche test hätte man aufgrund der radioaktivität
absolut bemerken müssen zudem sei ein weiteres problem technisch wohl noch längst nicht
Gelöst wie soll der atomreaktor während des fluges gekühlt werden
wo er doch durch die vorbeiströmende luft und die damit verbundene reibung sehr stark erhitzt werde fragen über fragen
Und bisher gibt es keine antworten wenn er als erstes erfahren wollt wenn es hier antworten gibt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von krieg zum mitmachen und mitbestimmen
Was hier bei pixum passiert und zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines geschenk von mir einfach hier?
draufklicken wir natürlich nicht das awo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
1000 raketen zum mars da geht es um die friedliche nutzung von
raketentechnik ansonsten bis dann
bleibt an